and it's like it's like and that's okay  but that doesn't mean women are being  discriminated against it means they  don't want to work 60 70 hours a week I  interviewed top like  um I decided I wanted more rich friends  when I lived in Milwaukee and I just  asked Executives if I could like a  billion dollar companies if I could sit  there have a coffee with them and just  interview them about their life and both  of them are that I got to interview I  could see the one deficit they had in  their life neither of them really had  families and it was really sad and you  can tell both of them like missed out on  a part of life and you could tell they  regretted it you can't have everything